Riley the limo driver Mun I didn't come  here to bury you Ronnie we all know  that's Thursday Ronnie watched his  parents  Ronnie watch his parents have a  threesome with the neighbor through the  bottom of the door and that's not the  weird part the weird part  he was i level with the bottom  Ronnie wants to open and run an animal  hospital in Las Vegas because really why  should humans be the only ones with  shitty luck in that town  Ronnie's also killing it on Twitter  these days and by it I mean women's sex  drive Ronnie loves NASCAR he hangs with  drivers like Tony Stewart even as a  nickname for Tony he calls him smoke  Tony has a nickname for Ronnie he calls  him loser [ __ ] wannabe Ronnie's love  of racing started as a kid when he got  been hers autograph after a race